and now the seven most badass dinosaurs
ever the pekus F Allah Soros this
herbivore has a thick bone plate on its
skull mostly for bashing in vegetables
scientists believe it's skull seriously
[ __ ] up in avocado the ankylosaurus
this dinosaur is like an armadillo
armadillos were a billion times bigger
and actually badasses
it has a club on its tail used for
balancing itself like use that thing to
beat the [ __ ] out of other dinosaurs the
Triceratops the classic horned Dino and
one of the original ballers of the
Dinosaur World the only way predators
could kill it was by biting its neck
plate and ripping its head off as cold
blood the elasmosaurus is the single
best reason of why you do not swim in
prehistoric waters it's like if a whale
and a snake made beautiful yet
terrifying love this thing was never
meant for this world it's an abomination
the Velociraptor the classic lizard
depiction wasn't quite accurate reality
they were chicken like and the size of a
small toddler still chicken toddler or
not those claws would make anyone poop
unexpectedly stegasaurus this dinosaur
has everything a Ridge of giant scales
on its spine a spiked club on its tail
and possibly an auxilary brain in its
bud you could say it's the butt head of
the Dinosaur World you'd be right
it'd also be a dick the Tyrannosaurus
Rex the king of dinosaurs the t-rex had
tiny arms because it didn't need to pick
anything up it just made other dinosaurs
pickups before him once in a while he
would eat one of those tiny dinosaurs
just to keep them in check but otherwise
it just kind of hung out do whatever it
wanted was the king and life was good
until the meteor